in fact this very
conversation is
multi uh level absurd so first of all I
should say that I just very recently had
a conversation with Jeff
Bezos and uh I would love to hear
your Beth
Jos opinions of Jeff Bezos speaking of
Intergalactic Jeff Bezos uh what do you
think of that particular individual whom
your name is inspired yeah I mean I
think Jeff is really great I mean he's
built one of the most epic companies of
all time he's leveraged the techn
capital machine and techn capital
acceleration
to give us what we wanted right we want
uh quick delivery very convenient at
home low prices right he
understood how the machine worked and
how to harness it right like running the
company uh not trying to take profits
too early putting it back putting
letting the system compound and keep
improving and you know arguably I think
Amazon's invested some of the most
amount of capital and Robotics out there
um and certainly with the birth of AWS
kind of um enabled the sort of tech boom
we've seen today that has paid the
salaries of you know I guess myself and
all of our friends to some extent
so I I think we can all be grateful to
you know Jeff and he's one of the great
entrepreneurs uh out there one of the
best of all time unarguably uh and of
course the the work at Blue origin
similar to the work at SpaceX is trying
to make humans a multiplanetary species
which seems almost like a bigger thing
than the capitalist machine or it's a
capitals machine at a different time
scale perhaps yeah I I think that um you
know
companies they tend to optimize you know
quarter over quarter maybe a few years
out but individuals that want to leave a
legacy can think on a multi-decadal or
multi-century time scale and so the fact
that some individuals are such good
Capital allocators that they unlock the
ability to allocate capitals to goals
that take us much further or much
further looking you know elon's doing
this with SpaceX putting all his Capital
towards getting us to Mars um uh Jeff is
trying to build blue origin and I think
he wants to build O'Neal cylinders and
get industry off Planet uh which I think
is brilliant um I think you know just
overall I'm I'm for billionaires I know
this controversial statement sometimes
but I think that uh in a sense it's kind
of a a proof of stake voting right like
if you've acquire if you've allocated
Capital efficiently you get you unlock
more Capital to allocate just because
clearly you know how to allocate Capital
more officially which is in contrast to
politicians that get elected because
they speak the best on TV right not
because they have a proven track record
of allocating taxpayer Capital most
efficiently and so that's why I'm for uh
capitalism uh over say giving all our
money to the government and letting them
figure out how to allocate it so so
yeah